we leave the stage when we want to see
the next if you can't wait for the next
game that's what football should be life
is so quick but it keeps you in the race
if you experience when experiences love
what you've done in the past technical
things are so important you cannot win
without technical things but the the the
emotion make the difference
he's a former professional football
player and the current manager of
Liverpool he spent most of his 15 year
playing career for one team and then
became their longest-serving manager
he's won the German football manager of
the Year twice he's Jurgen Klopp and
here's my take on his top ten rules of
success rule number nine is my personal
favourite and I'd love to know which one
you guys like the best also guys as
you're watching if you hear something
that really resonates with you please
leave it down the comments below put
quotes around it so other people could
be inspired by your sharing and also
when you write it down you're much more
likely to lock it in for yourself to
enjoy
for sure
we've only this one life and we should
make the best of it and that's what I
try to him
best to do the best is not to enjoy each
day as as it the last they are
celebrating drinking whatever because
tomorrow it could be the end no no it's
m2 to make it a better place but I think
it's only possible in your surrounding
you come in a room try that the people
don't feel rough and you come in so
that's what I try to that's how I
understand life and how would you
describe your footballing philosophy
lively I think it it's not the smartest
way I know so any trade and now if
general success day at the end they add
that how this a success rate at school
to but first of all having memorable
games in a row that's my first target
the people really want to see the next
game you leave the stage when you want
to see the next if you can't wait for
the next game that's what football
should be and if you can do this very
often and you will be successful 1% if
you always live in the future and hope
that something will change in the future
you forget that you have to change a lot
if you always have in the past exam
maybe for all people hopefully it's nice
and it's nice to think about wonderful
moments and things like this but we are
not in this thing it is facing our life
we are in there in the middle of our
life in the weather's the biggest
influence on everything and so we should
try to do what we can to make it better
if not for us than for our families of
our friends or whatever and that's
that's we'll drive it I think being 100%
in the moment it's the only possibility
to get better in the future we are not
on the world's to do to do every do what
everybody wants we have to to be a group
sometimes it's only family sometimes
it's with friends sometimes it's
together and how I understand it LLC is
family and football becomes the game it
is today because you work together and
in this moment we don't only have a
level
you should brought together not only 20
players not 24 players we have to work
together here in Melwood with all the
people working and fit with all the
supporters in liverpool with all the
supporters around the world that what I
what I believe in and then if you do
this if you are stronger than this we
will be succeed for sure we will succeed
for sure I had bigger challenges in my
life of course and my own careers player
and in my code Korea or magically and
yes at hard times in mind to stay in
Bundesliga with - that's the same
challenge it's Yugi lose think 60% of
the games but you have the chance to
stay in the league and yuto's you have
to learn to handle and these these
things and that's what I learned of
course of course it was always hard work
here and from the first day on but of
course it's not the biggest challenge
but it's then the most strange situation
because using football you all you're
responsible for all false you make yes
that's it that's really the true story
about football but in our situation we
had so many problems with injured
players and that yeah we had to work and
we had to do to stay confident to stay
self-confident for the moment when we
are ready to I know to run to to fight
in our best shape and that's what what
we had but in this time when we are when
we had to work well one match where the
next night every free day with a match
and so we went everything in chairman's
like everything in Cup and lost nearly
everything in Bundesliga it's really
strange it's really crazy situation but
we are we had to learn to handle it
because it was not it was not the
absolute surprise that we had problems
we need in you this season will be
problematic but m/m within universities
in this size the problem so we're where
to learn to handle it now
we are in the
iteration we know with what we have to
do the players came back to get in
better shape and so that it's very
important but we did only one step
against that but it's the only one now
the next challenge polygon then
Frankfort and so on so no easy game area
is always hard work and we try to do it
we really work hard that we can be as
successful as possible immediately but
success is there may be a different view
for it I would say this season going to
championship would be outstanding
success with all the quality round and
so there's one team all the more lucky
big quality and all that stuff no
injuries and Chelsea they did a
fantastic job so far if they do it again
can carry on like this and they'll be a
champion and they deserve it and all the
rest is fighting for the rest more or
less better or worse whatever in given
moment there's pressure on all of us we
will see we'll go through and but when
you get the target it's fantastic if you
don't get it doesn't mean you are you're
bad you are not the right person or
whatever touch me come on try it again
that's the thing when you are convinced
about the constellation you're convinced
about the people and in this moment
always think about alternatives that's
what I do always so if they're somebody
else it could be better if I would know
something could do better I would not be
here they ask him we can do it and
everything will be good so I'm really
I'm really convinced about the
circumstances on placing the bases we
are and that's what we want to use how
long it will take I have no idea but
everybody should see that we tried
really everyday really hard I don't live
in the past but I like all our it so
it's like the family father grandpa
loved things like this so there's always
a reason why you are here this is if you
want the grandfather and father of the
obscene they are the reason why we are
here the life is so quick but it keeps
you in the race if you experience we
experiences what you what you've done in
the past and and so that's sometimes you
can use the experience of other people
and that's what we try how would you
personally describe your style of
leadership
close to the human being I think
discipline is very important very
important that discipline is relative
especially preaching many work together
with young players and yet never lose
the target and I don't know how to say
that never lose the target always need
to stay focused on it so that that's
pretty clear because that and always and
yeah think it's still possible so that's
that not right well in English but here
yeah for sure the leaf it's a bit
different to believe the leaf is and you
can create you can believe in something
but you can lose believe quite easily so
to be stronger in a bad moments things
like this I watch so many metals in my
life unbelievable and they're really not
so there are some boring gigs and then
is asleep I'm so boring I think oh why
they meet each other and make this 20 40
50 60 70 80 thousand people in the
stadium when sparring game it's not ok
so that's what we what we want to see we
want to enjoy our own game if we lose ok
we like to win but if we lose with our
way it's ok if we lose with the way of
somebody else it's if you cannot work
with this so that's it it's very
emotional very fast very strong not
boring no chess like there is no yes of
course tactically has but detective with
with big heart and technical things are
so important you cannot win without
technical things but the emotion make
the difference life in our in our game
looks important your emotion on the side
of the pitch I watch you you you know
you gather as I develop a new address
only one part of me to be honest it's
most of the time I'm not that emotional
thank God so but during the game and
something happened to me I don't know
until now 49 I can't exactly explain
what it is but if I would see another
person doing what I do
I would think is he crazy
you can all stop just the top anymore
it's the whole ground forces awful you
know unlike us to stand up and everyone
the factual sergeant often o'clock grab
you watching the football because he's
thinking about it does mistake see what
ecological X so ominously fantastic
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Fernando Tavares
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down the comments below
and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know what did you learn
from this video that's going to have an
immediate impact on you somehow what
clip with your favorite and what are you
going to take immediate action on now in
your life of your business after
watching this video leave it down the
comments below and I'll join in the
discussion finally I want to give a
quick shout out to Kelly Quinton Kelly
thank you so much for picking up ten
copies of my book your one word and
sending it out to some of your friends I
really really really appreciate it and I
hope you and them are enjoying the book
as well so thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
so let's talk
or thing about football and let's play
football that's that's what we try with
all the pressure on it with all the
knowledge about how long it was since we
won last title but if you want it I
don't know 20-something years oh this is
the first year since we really try
really to win against something because
we all learn now from the past then it's
only on the ends and also that fits
better actually so we decide how it
should feel
and if they are patient enough I think a
lot of good things can happen here
that's what we have to learn we have to
take the games like they are we don't
have to - well you're right the gate
that the opponent before the game and
say against this it should be easy no
football game is easy so in that then
it's a question is it possible to create
a most special atmosphere at 3 o'clock
Saturday afternoon at Anfield more
special and in each another game is it
possible I would say yes so let's try it
and the atmosphere is to come to things
that's very important is to crawl Nets
the team so I can do a lot to bring us
in the right mood but them I really
would love to see that everybody goes
with the right expectation the game like
this and it's not disappointed enough
men will miss a chance in after 10
minutes and think are difficult again it
should be easier why should it be easier
when we can win against teams which the
people think they are stronger than we
are why another team which people think
is weaker than we are shouldn't have the
opportunity to win so that's a better
read up it's a process that's something
we have to we have really to learn it's
it's all we can always talk about the
same things we can always say but
against this team something was wrong
and it I can 100% guarantee it's not
about the attitude of the players 100%
so that they think that's why should we
put everything in this game and why
that's not about this so let's try to
create really an atmosphere which
everybody is completely in in the
performance in the game concentrated is
happy about creating moments happy about
creating chances missing chances
information not more
so it's always only that that we can
show yes we know how we can cause some
problems and if we stay then
concentrated patient but greedy and
direct yeah then we will have the next
one if we the more you have the more
likely is it that you use one